president Trump's pic of Judge Brett
Kavanaugh continues to generate an
enormous fallout president Trump goes in
hard at NATO and Sacha Baron Cohen
basically humiliates himself I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
as always many things are happening in
the news a lot of fallout from president
Trump's Supreme Court pick of Brett
Kavanaugh will talk all about that plus
we'll get to president Trump traveling
over to visit with NATO before his big
meet up with Vladimir Putin which is
happening in Northern Europe somewhere
they don't really care about but we will
get to all of that in just a second
first I want to mention to you that our
next episode of the conversation is
coming up quickly this Tuesday July 17th
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific all
of your questions will be answered by
our own Andrew Klavan with our host
Alicia Kraus a live Q&A will be
available on YouTube and Facebook for
everybody to watch but only subscribers
can ask drew questions over at daily
wire comm check out the pin comments on
this video for more information once
again subscribe to ask drew live
questions Tuesday July 17th at 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific and join the
conversation learn all about the
greatest good as bestest of all things
go check it out with Andrew Klavan next
week July 17 5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m.
at Pacific also let's say that you are a
lazy bum and you don't actually want to
go to the grocery and you don't know any
recipes because you don't know how to
cook
well there's one place that can make all
of this very easy for you that of course
would be the folks over at blue apron so
are you looking forward to honey
Chipotle glazed chicken with poblano and
lime rice that you cooked yourself how
about smoky depth being added to done
while enjoying the warm weather well
blue apron can make all that happen for
you you don't even know have to have to
know to cook they make all of this
happen very easily they provide you
convenience and variety by delivering
fresh pre-portion ingredients
step-by-step recipes directly to your
door all of them can be cooked in under
45 minutes the menu changes every week
based on what's in season it is designed
by blue aprons in-house killin' are a
team they also offer 12 new recipes
every week customers can pick two three
or four recipes based on what best fits
their schedule and all of their products
are just the finest they send only non
GMO ingredients meat with no added
hormones everything from blue apron
apparently is just terrific there are
bunch of people in the office who use it
blue apron has become the hot thing
around Los Angeles because who the hell
wants to go over to Whole Foods and wait
in line behind all the people driving
the Prius is when you can just have
excellent ingredients delivered to your
door with the recipe and then you cook
it with your family I really enjoy
cooking with my kids you're going to
enjoy cooking for yourself as well check
out this week's menu get your first
three meals for free at blue apron comm
slash Shapiro that's blue aprons comm
slash apparel again you get your first
three meals for free blue apron is
indeed a better
I'm honest in these recipes now and they
are just spectacular in barbecue
vegetable flatbread with Swiss cheese I
mean this is all gourmet stuff you're
cooking blue apron calm slash up here Oh
get your first three meals for free okay
so the left has no idea how to deal with
president Trump's pickle Brett Kavanaugh
because it turns out the Brett Kavanaugh
is a pretty well-respected jurist he's
been on the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
for 12 years he has 300 decisions to his
name and none of them are particularly
controversial now this is one of the
areas where I'm not the biggest
Cavanaugh fan is that I like judges who
are straightforward and open about their
beliefs about precedent and and how they
would rule in particular cases
unfortunately our system now favors
judges who are not quite as open about
all those things because we have to get
those people through confirmation
hearings and that is because of the
Democrats politicization of the court
beginning with justice or should have
been Justice Robert Bork back in the
1980s when Ted Kennedy and Joe Biden
decided to destroy the man's life for no
reason other than he disagreed with them
about constitutional interpretation
Cavanaugh is providing all sorts of
problems for Democrats who have no clue
exactly how to handle him and naturally
this means the Democrats folks on the
Left are blaming Republicans for
politicizing the court so the fact is
that it was not Republicans who
politicized the court it was Democrats
who decided that they were going to use
the court as a political tool openly and
this begins all the way back in the
1930s when a lot of FDR's New Deal
program was unconstitutional it violated
the bounds of the Constitution and the
court said it violated the bounds of the
Constitution and so FDR threatened to
pack the courts he threatened to
increase the number of justices on the
Supreme Court
from 9 to 15 and he offered that he was
going to push in a bunch of Democrats
who were going to just greenlight
everything he did and to the court in
order to protect itself basically ruled
that all of his nonsensical programs
that lengthened the Great Depression by
up to eight years that all these
programs were actually constitutional
they get a spate of horrific decisions
in the 1930s and 1940s basically
sanctioning enormous government growth
up to and including the worst case maybe
in in constitutional history just in
pure legal terms Wickard V filburn a
case in which the Supreme Court held
that you could not grow grain in your
backyard for your own use without the
federal government intervening the
federal government had a right to
intervene in you growing stuff in your
own backyard
because that would affect Commerce
somehow in some vague way well now
because President Trump has gotten two
picks in the last year and a half
Democrats are now
seeing that it's Republicans who are
politicizing the court even though it
was Democrats who originally politicized
the court and have continued to do so by
treating the court as a super legislator
super legislature of genius wise
liberals who are going to impose their
viewpoint on the rest of us and these
are the people who worship the altar of
the notorious Ruth Bader Ginsburg hey
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's decisions are
garbage
okay I've read a lot of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's decisions none of them have
anything to do with the Constitution all
of them have everything to do with her
personal politics but she's the
notorious RBG notorious and can you
imagine if conservatives lionized to
anyone like that notorious RBG and the
closest they came with sort of this lion
ization of Scalia even that never
approached the sort of cult hero status
where you were worrying about how her
workout routines went BuzzFeed ran an
entire piece like three days ago about
Ruth Bader Ginsburg's grueling workout
routine the woman's 85 okay if her
routine is that grueling then she'd be
dead but here is what the New York Times
writes today or at least Lee Epstein and
Eric Posner Epstein a political science
scientist and law professor at
Washington University and Posner a
professor at University of Chicago Law
School write about the the move by
President Trump to put originalist on
the court here's what they write in the
New York Times president Trump was
always going to pick a conservative for
the Supreme Court
the only question has been whether to
replace Justice Anthony Kennedy with a
business conservative or a religious
conservative no one seriously thought he
would consider a moderate a liberal or
an ideologically ambiguous replacement
first of all these categories you'll
notice that whenever I talk about the
Supreme Court I never talk about a
conservative justice the reason I don't
talk about a conservative justice is
because a judge should not let his or
her political proclivities influence the
decision-making I always talk about an
originalist justice or a textualist
justice somebody who is actually going
to interpret the words of the law as
they were written and as they were
understood at the time that is not the
same thing as a conservative justice who
would presumably just rule in favor of
whichever interest he thought was most
compelling politically and so it's only
the left it talks about openly political
judges says well we need a moderate or a
liberal on the court they say well sure
enough Brett Kavanaugh is a conservative
in good standing well Brett Kavanaugh is
actually a textualist in pretty good
standing and the New York Times
continues these two professors they say
the next democratic president will
nominate a liberal to the court in the
hope of tilting it in the other
direction
everyone is so accustomed to the state
of affairs people have forgotten to
question it but we wonder whether a
Supreme Court that is come to be rigidly
divided by both by ideology and party
can sustain public confidence for much
longer
weird how they only have this problem
when it comes to Republicans replacing
Republican appointees with other
Republican appointees I don't remember
them having the same problem when a
lay-in elena kagan who's a wild leftist
and Sonia Sotomayor who is an even
Wilder leftist were appointed to the
court by Barack Obama
it's amazing by the way you want to know
how non-ideological Republicans have
been about the court there's a very easy
proof Republicans have been in about 500
when it comes to good Supreme Court
picks for every Scalia there was a in
O'Connor for every Thomas there was a
Souter for every Rehnquist there was a
John Paul Stevens for every for every
Alito there was a roberts there was
always somebody who was being appointed
who I met great but for Democrats they
never get it wrong why because they
actually do have ideological lemmas
tests and because when you are not tied
to the words of the Constitution and the
meaning of the Constitution this leaves
you free to pick among the various
solutions that most appeal to you
personally you end up very quickly
picking somebody who agrees with you
politically but according to these
professors at the New York Times it's
the right that's politicized the court
they say the court has recently entered
a new era of partisan division if you
look at close cases five to four or five
to three going back to the 50s to
illustrate this division you'll see that
the percentage of votes cast in liberal
direction by justices who are appointed
by Democratic presidents has skyrocketed
and the same trajectory applies on the
other side the percentage of votes cast
in the conservative direction by
justices who are appointed by
Republicans has also shot up now the
reason for that is because of the rise
of the Federalist societies the
Federalist Society is a conservative
minded group an originalist minded
groups that are conservative politically
but they're more originalist and
textualist than anything else I'd say
politically they're actually closer to
libertarian and that group has done a
better job of vetting Republican
candidates this is why I'm not concerned
that Cavanaugh is gonna end up like
David Souter the reason being when David
Souter was appointed you didn't have
large groups of people who were devoted
to vetting David suitors record now you
have enormous groups of people who came
with the touch of a button pull up every
decision Cavanaugh has ever written on
and then analyze it for signs of exactly
how he will rule in the future it is
good that we are treating the supreme
court with this level of care and in his
demonstrative of the fact that as soon
as conservatives woke up and started
realizing that the Supreme Court was
being
used as a tool of policy by the left
they started making sure that appointees
to the Supreme Court might actually have
to reflect an originalist or textual
event but according to these these
professors at the New York Times they
say this is a bad thing they say this
trend is extreme and alarming in the
1950s and 60s the ideological biases of
Republican appointees and Democratic
appointees were relatively modest the
gap between them has steadily grown but
even as late as the early 1990s it was
possible for justices to vote in
ideologically unpredictable ways in a
closely divided cases in the 1991 term
for example the single Democratic
appointee on the court Byron white voted
more conservatively than all but two of
the Republican appointees Antonin Scalia
and William Rehnquist this was at a time
when many Republican appointees like
Sandra Day O'Connor Harry Blackmun John
Paul Stevens and David Souter frequently
cast liberal votes that's because
conservatives had done a crappy job and
that's also because Byron White was
appointed way back when right Byron
white the justices on the Supreme Court
he was originally appointed if I am not
mistaken by President John F Kennedy so
the Democratic Party back in 1960 was
not the same as the Democratic Party
became in 1990 by the time Byron white
was ruling on the court I mean this is a
reality is that the Democratic Party in
the Republican Party in 1960 were much
closer on policy than the Democratic
Party and the Republican Party by 1990
in the past 10 years they write in the
New York Times justices have hardly ever
voted against the ideology of the
President to appoint to them only
Justice Kennedy name to the court by
Ronald Reagan did so with any regularity
now I don't think this is actually true
if you look at how Justice Scalia voted
on some civil libertarian issues he was
constantly sort of surprising people on
how he voted on a lot of those issues
and the same thing will probably hold
true of I think maybe Gorsuch maybe but
the fact is that Democrats never vote
Democrat appointees now never vote
against Democratic Policy Priorities
ever even in the most extreme cases and
if they do it's only on the narrowest of
grounds and these these professors say
it's hard to think of any historical
precursors the most famous period of
ideological division on the court was in
the 1930s when it repeatedly struck down
liberal legislation but what is
remarkable is that the division was not
strongly partisan among the four
horsemen the die-hard opponents of the
New Deal one was appointed by a
Democratic president another was a
Democrat appointed by a Republican
president among the three justices who
typically voted to uphold the luteal
programs two are appointed by Republican
presidents again that's because the
party's them
were much closer an ideological
orientation during the FDR period
remember Herbert Hoover imposed
basically the same policies that FDR did
just in slightly smaller scale so these
these professors Eric Posner and and Lee
Epstein they continue by suggesting that
all of this changed in the 1950s and 60s
they say the war in court was not
partisan two of its liberal stalwarts
William Brennan and Earl Warren were
appointed by Dwight Eisenhower
Republican again for the 30th time
Dwight Eisenhower was a very very
moderate Republican in fact he was so
moderate that in 1948 the Democrats
seriously considered the possibility of
having Dwight Eisenhower run on the
Democratic ticket in 48 and 52 if I'm
not mistaken the Warren Court took a
liberal stand on the most controversial
issues of the day including civil rights
sexual freedom and the rights of
criminal suspects in political
dissenters the post-war court case of
roe v wade finally galvanized the right
and that is correct because Republicans
basically started seeing that the court
was going to be used as a club but only
now apparently are they upset about this
they say frustrated with the Supreme
Court's opinions his opposition to the
New Deal president FDR tried to pack the
court that is add more justices although
the plan died in Congress the court also
backed down from confrontation with the
president both Roosevelt and the court
were badly damaged by the clash today we
see similar attacks on the judiciary in
Hungary Poland and other a liberal
democracies assaults on judicial
independence are made easier when the
public comes to view the judiciary as a
political body this risk and not just
the identity of the next justice should
be at the center of public attention
well that wouldn't be a risk if the left
hadn't already politicized the court end
of story
that's why we are having these battles
it's because the Left decided that the
court was going to be a tool of policy
that it was not actually going to be a
tool on behalf of the Constitution of
the United States ok so I want to talk a
little bit more about that and explain
why the left is so exercised over Brett
Kavanaugh in just a second first let's
talk about your hair so look up top
dudes particularly look up top you're
missing some hair aren't you and that's
because your dad is missing some hair or
your grandpa's missing some here well
there is no reason you actually have to
lose all the rest of that hair there is
a real solution there are two clinically
proven medications that let you keep
your hair and they are now inexpensive
and easy to get you don't need to lose
that hair if you don't want to and
that's why I need to tell you about
keeps for five minutes now in just a
buck a day you won't have to worry about
hair loss ever again getting started
with keeps is really easy sign up takes
less than five minutes you answer a few
questions you snap some photos you can
do it from your computer right just turn
on photobooth or use your phone and then
you send those
to a licensed doctor who remotely
reviews the information and recommends
the right treatment for you all without
ever leaving your couch keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there someone probably tried them before
they've never gotten them this easily
for this price keeps his only ten bucks
to 35 bucks a month it's a lot a lot
cheaper than getting these same drugs
from from a local pharmacy now you can
get that first month for free as well
which is a great deal go check it out
keeps calm / Ben to receive your first
month treatment for free go to keeps
calm / man that's ke EPS calm / man
that's a free month of treatment again
keeps calm / menus that / man so that
they know that we sent you okay so the
left is really exercised over Brett
Kavanaugh because they recognize that
the right in attempting to Rican Street
wits traditional role of interpreting
the Constitution rather than imposing
political priorities that this threatens
the left's agenda the left believes that
its agenda can only be spread not
through public legislation not through
the popularity of its agenda but just by
a bunch of people who are really really
wise and liberal and who can impose
their views from above and so the idea
of a Brett Kavanaugh who's gonna come in
and help create a new majority on the
court that's actually gonna stick to the
judiciary's job that scares the living
hell it's cuz living daylights out of
Democrats and so they're just lying
about Brett Kavanaugh now so the first
like they're telling is they are
suggesting that President Trump is
appointing Brett Kavanaugh because Brett
Kavanaugh is going to protect president
Trump from impeachment this is
legitimately what they are saying so
Chuck Schumer is making this case he
says this is the real reason that Trump
wants Kavanagh he was the judge probably
of the 25 they all would repeal Roe they
all would repeal ACA but on this issue
the mulher issue which came up after the
vetting by these two groups he's
probably the most extreme and it
wouldn't surprise me if that was very
important to Donald Trump
knowing Donald Trump and I have no proof
do you think he didn't inquire about
this every word of that every word of
what Chuck Schumer just said is a lie
first of all not every judge on that
list would vote to overturn Roe in fact
I have serious doubts that Cavanaugh
will vote to overturn Roe we'll get to
that in just a little while this
implication that Cavanaugh is somehow
going to protect the President of the
United States from criminal indictment
is just not true it not only is it not
true even the Washington Post says it's
not true so the accusation is that
Cavanaugh in 2009 published
article in the Minnesota law review in
which he discussed the possibility of
indicted a sitting president of the
United States criminally and here is
what he says according to the Washington
Post and not according to me not
according to National Review according
to the left-wing Washington Post
Cavanaugh helped investigate President
Bill Clinton as part of independent
counsel Kenan stars team in the 1990s
looking back Cavanaugh wrote in his 2009
article the nation certainly would have
been better off if President Clinton
could have focused on Osama bin Laden
without being distracted by the Paula
Jones sexual harassment case and its
criminal investigation offshoots which
is an interesting switch by Cavanaugh
who was part of again the Ken Starr team
what he says the president should not be
indicted but he says you needed an act
of Congress to prevent the president
from being indicted in other words it's
not up to the judiciary to protect the
president the president can be indicted
the Constitution doesn't prevent that
you need an act of Congress that's not
stopping the left from continuously
lying about Brett Kavanaugh you've got
Alexandra oak Ozzy Cortez new left-wing
hero shoots she tweets out the fact that
Scott is pick Kavanagh believes the
president cannot be indicted is an
automatic disqualification from a
Supreme Court consideration he never
said that he never believed that he's
never written that but these lies are
coming fast and furious about Kavanagh
that's not that's not even the stupidest
one we'll get to a couple more that are
incredibly dumb so let's begin
with narrow pro-choice America so near
all is of course an abortion rights an
abortion rights group and here is what
they tweeted out red is 15 here's what
they tweeted out they tweeted out back
off Brett and with their with the
clapping hands first of all you who use
the clapping hands emoji stop it
and make yourself look like a douche
it's stupid and the clapping hands
emojis are dumb unless you're using them
ironically it's one of those things like
using the word woke if you use the word
woke ironically then I'm okay with you
woke without any sense of irony about
your own douchiness then I have nothing
to say to you and the same thing is true
about the clapping hands emergency emoji
so it's a back ah bread okay you're an
idiot
okay here's what Niro actually tweeted
we'll be damned
dams all caps if we're gonna let five
men including some frat boy named Brett
strip us of our hard-won bodily autonomy
and reproductive rights first of all
it's not hard-won bodily autonomy in
reproductive rights that's the entire
point you couldn't pass legislation it
was handed to you on a platter by the
supreme court I'd say it wasn't hard one
bottle
autonomy and reproductive rights first
of all even if you think that killing a
baby in your womb is bodily autonomy you
didn't win anything near all pro-choice
America you won nothing
it was a Supreme Court that handed use
stuff on a silver platter because the
American people don't agree with your
agenda polls show that even pro-choice
Americans are very much in favor of
restrictions on second and third
trimester abortions for example my
favorite part of the sweet dough is
where they suggest that Brett Kavanaugh
is some frat boy named Brett have you
like seen Brett Kavanaugh have it looked
at Brett Kavanaugh you think he's going
in like he's doing he's like chugging
beer with the bros in in the aftermath
of his of his DC Circuit Court cases
when he was in place beer pong after
making his decisions he's going he's
butt chuggin things like that so that's
Brett Kavanaugh I mean really I'm gonna
go no on that frat boy named Brett Brett
Kavanaugh has been on the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals for 12 years before
that who's involved in virtually every
level level of federal litigation Brett
Kavanaugh is about the nerdiest guy you
will ever find he is a hardcore Catholic
who sends his daughters to Catholic
school coaches his daughter's basketball
team and and volunteers at the soup
kitchen frat boy named Brett and then
and then they but were the sexist or the
sexist all men who don't believe the
same things that NER all believes that
are their frat boys I love that the the
the left has been relegated to mocking
Brett Cavanaugh's first name like really
this is a thing now they've got nothing
so they're now relegated to mocking
Brent Cavanaugh's first name so Stephen
Colbert he starts he has nothing on
Cavanaugh he's got nothing to say so
here is what he says about Cavanaugh we
can't have a guy in the Supreme Court
named Brett like what's next gonna have
a guy in the Supreme Court named Paisley
like what's gonna happen say here's
Stephen Colbert making the very solid
case you should never have someone on
the Supreme Court
named Brett because something I don't
know much about Kavanagh but I'm
skeptical because his name is Brett that
sounds less like a Supreme Court justice
and more like a waiter at Ruby Tuesday's
hey everybody I'm Brett I'll be your
Supreme Court justice tonight before you
sit down let me just clear away these
rights for you
what like that's your case and that's
you that's a real strong case right
there that his name is Brett what are we
in third grade hey Brett can't be a
Supreme Court just I mean his name is
Brett also like there there have been a
fair number of actual prominent Brett's
in American public life including of
course Brett Favre who was a very manly
man and not the Brett at Ruby Tuesday's
but in any case and Stephen Colbert I
mean if I I will say Stephen Colbert is
right my understanding is that Stephen
Colbert actually changed the
pronunciation of his name in college
this is the rumor that was going on is
that Stephen Colbert is actually
pronounced even Kolbert and he actually
changed it to Colbert because it sounds
more sophisticated in any case
Brett sounds like a manager at Ruby
Tuesday's which apparently is a bad
thing apparently it's terrible to work
at Ruby Tuesday's it means that you're
unqualified for anything so menial
laborers you know never aspire to go to
law school nobody who has ever worked at
Ruby Tuesday's every went on to go be a
lawyer no one they all stayed there
forever and they were Flair that's
that's what they did and but Stephen
Colbert going after Brett Kavanaugh his
name Stephen Colbert that's the name
that sounds to me like a failed comedian
like if I just had to pull out of the
air I would just say Stephen Colbert
sounds like a dude who can't make a good
joke that's that's what I would probably
say about it my favorite rip on Kavanagh
however goes to Joy Behar so Joy Behar
who legitimately has the IQ of a kumquat
I mean the woman is just
inane she she says this about my cabin
oh she says that Brett Kavanaugh is
basically judge Jeanine Pirro yeah okay
it is not judge Jeanine Pirro
which I at one point in time thought was
actually a possibility in court this so
so he's have been worse for you it could
have been much worse well he died Mike
GB just acquired a version of Judge
renamed she's a more he's a more what
he's a he's a better version of judge
Jeanine
he's a quieter version of judge Jeanine
yeah if you're a nut case if you were
dropped on your head as a baby if you
fell off the stupid train you had every
branch on the way down he's just like
judge Jeanine except for nothing except
for you know his wisely considered and
brilliant defenses that run like 50
pages at a time yeah listen I know judge
Jeanine I like judge Jeanine
but judge Jeanine gives speeches where
at the end of her speeches she literally
says I'm right how do you know cuz I'm
the judge
I've literally seen her give speeches
like that because she's a television
performance witch
does okay I've never seen a judge
Cavanaugh decision or at the end he says
and I'm right how do you know cuz I'm
the DC Circuit Judge no no but then but
the level of stupidity to which the left
is subjecting itself is truly
astonishing we'll get to more of this in
just a second and we'll get to Roby way
to end President Trump going after NATO
in pretty strong fashion but first let's
talk about movement watch it so movement
makes the best stuff I mean there it
really is great I have to movement
watches this right here this is a
movement watch you see the Queen Sparrow
design all it does is tell the time in
beautiful fashion it is magnificent also
these watches are incredibly durable
my son particularly loves these watches
which means he carries them around and
bashes the living crap out of them and
they somehow survive and look exactly
the same as the day that I got them
movement started off from being
crowdfunded kids working out of a living
room and they have grown like crazy they
now have all but almost two million
watches sold in 160 plus countries and
they continue to revolutionize fashion
on the belief that style should not
break the bank their watches are about
looking good keeping it simple you're
not gonna get it sitting you know an
iWatch okay it's not gonna be telling
you your texts it's not gonna be telling
you you know how many calories you burn
today it's going to be telling you the
time which is what you want out of a
watch because it's a watch it's not a
computer you'll want to strap a laptop
to your wrist you want an actual watch
that just looks nice for ninety five
bucks that's where their watches started
a department store you're looking at
four hundred five hundred bucks moomin
figured out by selling online they could
cut out the middleman and retail markup
and they could provide the best possible
price classic design quality
construction style minimalism a lot of
my fans have movement watches that's
happening for a reason go check it out
at MVM t.com slash shapiro and get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns
that's MVM t-dot-com slash shapiro check
out their expanding collection they also
have today they also have like now buy
thing bracelets and sunglasses and a
bunch of other stuff as well
MVM t comm slash shapiro join the
movement go check it out
really good stuff okay so these
stupidity about Brett Kavanaugh does not
end there a bunch of yale law students
decided to write an open letter about
Brett Kavanaugh and it's this long
letter about how horrible judge
Cavanaugh is and they suggest that
Cavanaugh is going to is going to lead
to death yeah this is an open letter
from Yale law students alumni and
educators regarding Brett Kavanaugh it
says to Dean gherkin and the Yale Law
School leadership we write today as Yale
law students alumni and educators I
shave
of our alma mater it first of all I'm
not sure about your writing to the Yale
Dean like he's not the one who votes for
a bunch of alumni of a law school they
probably should know how judicial
confirmations work how's here's not they
don't work that the the alumnus of the
particular Law School has to go and get
his approval from the Dean of the law
school he went to 30 years ago that's
how it doesn't work okay they the way
that it does work is that the Senate
advise and consent so I love that they
are writing this letter to the Dean of
the Yale Law School as though the Dean
is gonna be you know what you're
absolutely right yeah we're done
Cavanaugh's not in anymore
I am using my prerogative under Article
93 of the Constitution of the United
States as Dean of his former Law School
I have now rolled the Brett Kavanaugh is
no longer available for the for the
Supreme Court
sure well good good stuff guys he says
we write today as Yale Law Students
alumni and educators ashamed of our alma
mater why is he like judge Justice Roger
tawny is he's he gonna rule on Dred
Scott no he just disagrees with you
within an hour of Donald Trump's
announcement he would nominate Brett
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court the Law
School published a press release
boasting of at alumnus accomplishment
right because he went to Yale Law School
and wouldn't you boast if wanna yell
school Law School alumnus was going to
be on the Supreme Court the school's
post included quotes from Yale Law
School professors about Judge
Cavanaugh's intellect to influence and
mentorship of their students yet the
press releases focus on the nominees
professionalism pedigree and service the
Yale Law School obscures the true stakes
of his nomination and raises a
disturbing question is there nothing
more important to Gale Law School than
its proximity to power and prestige well
no that's pretty much it I mean like I
went I went to Harvard Law when I was at
Harvard Law the Dean of our school
wasn't woman named Elena Kagan you may
remember Elena Kagan from such shows as
I'm on the Supreme Court now okay so
Elena Kagan literally our first day at
Law School I remember this vividly our
first day at Law School we have an
orientation and we go into this this
beautiful hall I'd only was Whitner hall
but we went into this this beautiful hog
and still pictured it looks like
something out of Hogwarts all mahogany
busts of people from famous judges
everyone and she stands up says listen
you're at Harvard Law School the
competition is over you know you've seen
the Paper Chase and you've heard all
about how it's gonna be brutal
competition people fighting each other
it's not like that at all everybody here
is gonna do fine you're all gonna have
jobs you never gonna have to worry again
which is basically true you go to
Harvard Law
and law firms literally come to Harvard
Law to recruit students like you get to
pick your employer not the other way
around is basically how it works in
Harvard Law and so she's giving the
speech and then she says listen we have
I think at the time for Supreme Court
justices 30 odd senators we have a
hundred people in Congress you in this
room in the next 10 to 15 years the
people in this room will be ruling the
world that is how people think including
Elena Kagan at major law schools you
know why because that's a bunch of high
IQ people in that room and it's not the
job of Yale Law School to determine how
Brett Kavanaugh things is the job of
Yale Law School to determine whether
they have been successful in training a
lawyer prominent enough to reach the
level of the Supreme Court maybe one
thing Brett Kavanaugh or some sort of
Richard Spencer esque neo-nazi but
there's no evidence of any of that so
this letter is incredibly stupid and
then it just goes on and on and on
they say that Yale Law School should
show moral courage by withdrawing
support yo Law School doesn't
necessarily support Kavanagh they just
said by the way guys we have another guy
who's gonna be on the Supreme Court
so justjust geniuses all the way around
and the one who I'm most disappointed in
is Alan Dershowitz so Alan Dershowitz
who has been complaining that he has
been excised from all of the nice
parties over at Martha's Vineyard you
know in the great battle of Martha's
Vineyard has been taking place it's just
like the civil war over there and Alan
Dershowitz is on the view and he starts
mouthing off about Merrick garland and
how the Merrick garland seat was stolen
by the Republicans and then he drops
some bizarro language here he should
have nominated Merrick garland and
should have sworn him in and should have
dared the Republicans to say kick him
out of all we agree of it because they
have no right not to decide a case the
Constitution says advice and consent
it doesn't say delay and his bone um no
that's what advice and consent mean you
could just refuse to give your consent I
like that Alan
so bye Alan Dershowitz is Canada let's
let's use the word consent in a
different context let's he's in the
context of sex because that's where we
are almost familiar with it now in the
me to era so normally when we say that
you require consent this requires you
know consent and if you don't give
consent then you have not consented
because that's how consent works
according to Alan Dershowitz
when the Constitution says advise and
consent that doesn't mean
pone it doesn't mean delay it means you
have to give it an up or down vote in
other words there's no such thing as yes
means yes for the for the Supreme Court
apparently according to Alan Dershowitz
none of this makes any sense but at
least maybe he'll get to go back to some
of those cocktail parties on Martha's
Vineyard okay but the stupidity doesn't
only emerge from the left when it comes
to the Supreme Court
sometimes it emerges from people who are
quasi on the right the latest evidence
is Tommy Lehren so I don't want to rip
on Tommy Lehren too much I think the
Tommy Lehren has her heart in the right
place sometimes I think that she hasn't
studied these issues particularly well I
think that her I think that her ideas on
abortion are inane to put it mildly and
chews on Fox and Friends this morning
and she was talking about roe v-- wade
and and soon to be justice Kavanagh
using her vast legal experience to delve
into the intricacies of Supreme Court
precedent and here was Tommy Lehren
explaining why conservatives really
should just let roe v-- wade alone some
of my fellow conservatives who have put
it out there that we are quote coming
for roe v wade that is a mistake because
we are putting it out there and implying
that we are sending a justice justice to
the bench to carry out religious
judicial activism which is a mistake and
is unconstitutional and if we as
conservatives are going to imply that if
that's going to be our messaging we
might as well spit on the Constitution
that is not what we stand for read a
book a book aa book not lots of them one
okay like one do not Harry Potter I mean
like a book about the kind of like read
the Constitution we can start with that
read the Constitution and you show me
where in the Constitution there's a
right to abortion and then we can start
talking about whether this is a
religious edict trying to take down roe
v wade I mean honestly honestly it's
just make a logical argument make a good
argument that's not a good argument and
I got into a little bit of Tommy Lehren
over over the last couple of days
because I suggested she made a similar
argument on Twitter I said it was a dumb
argument she said you can't tell me what
to do and I'm getting real sick of
people on the right saying to me you
can't tell me what to do I'm not telling
you what to do I'm saying what you
should do if you are an intelligent
person and that would be maybe read
enough to defend your position well
let's be real real about this the reason
people oppose roe v wade is not just
because they are against abortion if
they were just against abortion then
they would presumably be pushing for a
to tional amendment to ban abortion
across the country or federal
legislation to ban abortion across the
country that would be the primary focus
the constitutional amendment the reason
that there are so many people on the
right who hate roe v-- wade is not just
because it is an immoral outcome but
because it has nothing to do with the
Constitution I can't name a single
person a single legal theorist on the
right
who says I oppose roe v wade because I'm
a religious person not one the reason
you oppose roe v wade is because it has
nothing to do with the Constitution it
is a garbage legal decision even people
on the Left who are honest will
acknowledge that while they like the
outcome of roe v wade it has nothing to
do with the law and has nothing to do at
the Constitution and playing into this
propaganda effort by the left to suggest
that it's just a bunch of religious
fanatics who wanna overturn roe v wade
is deeply irresponsible by Tommy Lynn
Turin deeply irresponsible it's also
really establishment I mean that's the
part of this that's so ironic is that
you know Tommy Lehren and some people
who are her fans of hers are suggesting
that you know it's it's
anti-establishment to suggest that roe v
wade should be upheld
and that we should stay away from social
issues Donald Trump ran on social issues
hidden run away from them
he ran basically on cultural social
issues and he won beyond that it was the
establishment that's been saying for
most of my adult lifetime that social
issues should be avoided at all cost was
focused on economics it's focused on
foreign policy I've been saying for
years that Republicans running away from
social policy is foolish because people
actually want to hear about the morality
of politics but you know that I wish
that I'm struggling for words here
because again I don't want to rip on
Tommy learn but when you say stuff this
ignorant Lee with this much conference
then you need to be called out for it
because this is just not true and it's
not right and I don't know what you
think she's doing here okay we're gonna
talk about Trump at NATO in just a
second but first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire and subscribe so for
$9.99 a month you can become a
subscriber to daily wire comm when you
do you get the rest of this show live
you get the rest of the Andrew Clavin
show live the rest of Michael Noel's
show live you also get to be part of the
conversation so on Tuesday Clavin will
be here answering all of your questions
and you get to ask him questions on
Friday you get to actually listen to my
show and then ask me questions live
which is pretty awesome
so go check that out for the annual
subscription you also get this then
leftist cheers hot or cold tumblr it has
been a flowing freely over the last
several weeks so go check that out as
well also please subscribe over at
youtube and at iTunes because every
we have the Sunday special the Sunday
special features one of the nation's
best thinkers this Sunday we are having
on my good friends Dennis Prager and we
gonna chat about his new book at the
rationale Bible so last week we had Sam
Harris this week we're having Dennis
Prager can't think of two sides of the
coin better than that so here is Dennis
Prager talking a little bit about that
hi I'm Dennis Prager and I'm the next
guest on the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special
I certainly hope you'll watch the
subject is my book my latest book the
rationale Bible and if you think the
Bible is nonsense
in fact especially if you think that I
invite you to watch me so go subscribe
check it out I really love these our
lone conversations I enjoy doing them I
think you'll really enjoy them as well
because they really are in-depth so
subscribe at YouTube subscribe at iTunes
leave us a review it always helps we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile president Trump has
traveled over to Brussels to meet with
the leaders over at NATO and he's thrown
bricks I mean he's not going in there
gentle he is he is going in there in in
very forward fashion shall we say here
with President Trump he tweeted this out
from the White House account this video
of him slamming NATO for their levels of
defense spending now I think that a lot
of what President Trump is saying is
true here I also think that there is a
bit of an optical problem in explain why
President Trump is both right and wrong
here because I think that's probably the
best description here he is slamming
NATO for its levels of defence spending
[Music]
so if you go back 10 or 20 years you've
just added it all up it's mess up
amounts of money is owed the United
States is paid and stepped up like
nobody Germany is just being a little
bit over 1% whereas the United States
and actual numbers is paying four point
two percent of a much larger GDP so I
think that's inappropriate also you know
we're protecting Germany were protecting
France we're protecting everybody and
yet we're paying a lot of money to
protect okay so this is Trump suggesting
that back in 2014 Barack Obama signed a
deal with all these European nations was
basically a pledge that they would raise
the percentage of their GDP that went to
defense spending to 2% of GDP now what
Trump is saying which is that these
countries OS money is not true
they don't tell what's money okay it was
never that they were going to sign us a
check at any point and we're spending on
our own defense because we want to spend
on our own defense but he is not wrong
when he says you guys you want to spend
less money than you should on your own
defense and then you expect us to come
save you if something goes totally wrong
like that part is actually sort of true
and Jim Garrity has a really good piece
today over at National Review on exactly
what it is that President Trump is
talking about he says that because
President ROM continued along these
lines play a little more president Trump
here he went after Germany because says
listen Germany you're spending 1% of
your GDP on defense and then you're
complaining that Russia is being really
aggressive well then why are you signing
massive natural gas deals with Russia at
the same
that you're spending 1% of your GDP not
2% of your GDP on national defense and
then expecting the United States to rush
in and save you from Russia Trump is not
totally wrong here here he is explaining
Germany is totally controlled by Russia
because they were getting from 60 to 70
percent of their energy from Russia and
a new pipeline and you tell me if that's
appropriate because I think it's not and
I think it's a very bad thing for NATO
and I don't think it should have
happened ok so the idea that Germany is
totally controlled by Russia is of
course to trumpian overstatement but
he's not totally wrong here so here's
what Jim Garrity writes as usual Trump
is down the street and around the corner
from a legitimate point well actually is
a little bit closer this time if you
think Trump's past business connections
to Russian figures are troubling you
probably ought to be livid about how
former German Chancellor Gerhard
schröder has decided to become the chief
lobbyist for Vladimir Putin in Europe
one of Shorter's last acts in office in
2005 was authorizing Nordstrom a
pipeline bypassing key territories and
controlled by Russia's Gazprom energy
company shortly after leaving office
Vladimir Putin arranged for Schroder to
chair the project and then he started
pushing for a second pipeline Nordstrom
- instead of diversifying Europe's
energy supply Schroder pushed policies
that make the content in the continent
more dependent on Russia not less in
September 2017 Putin arranged for
Schroder to become a chairman of Rosneft
the state-owned Russian oil giant The
Wall Street Journal's Holmen Jenkins
wrote earlier this year showed us
exactly the kind of wealthy
well-connected influential figure acting
on behalf of Russia the US sanctions are
supposed to target and Schroeder's been
hanging out with Putin at the World Cup
how is it in an era when the u.s.
politics is suddenly deeply concerned
someone's a paranoid about Russian
influence that Schroeder's cheerful
embrace of lobbying for Russia has
barely made a ripple on this side of the
pond the cynical answer is that most of
those screaming the loudest about Russia
today don't think of Putin as sinister
because of his lack of criticism of
Trump they think of Trump as sinister
Putin indeed Russia shot down a
passenger airliner over Ukraine in 2014
it was out of the news within a week but
their cynicism doesn't change the fact
that Russia is generally hostile to
American policies under presidents of
either party and Vladimir Putin would
love to see NATO alliances collapse in
that like the reluctance of some NATO
members to honor their agreements and
spend the required 2% of GDP on military
spending is baffling in 2017 just four
member states hit that 2% threshold the
u.s. Greece the UK and Estonia and will
give
Poland the benefit of the doubt because
it was barely under 2% Luxembourg ranked
last they last they spent less than 1/2
of 1% on their military perhaps
Luxembourg's leaders figured that
they're nestled between France Germany
and Belgium so they can count on their
neighbors to slow down any invading
Russians but NATO members in Eastern
Europe have no excuse Hungary is only
spending 1% so the point here is that
Trump isn't totally wrong about all of
this now
there's an upside to Trump pushing this
which is that he's correct the downside
is that it makes it look like NATO is a
fracturing fragmenting alliance and the
second I'm going to talk about Angela
Merkel's response to all this and why
this isn't an unmitigated good what
President Trump is saying here so
president Trump trying to get the
Europeans to spend what they shouldn't
on their national defense I don't think
that's the world's most terrible thing I
think in fact that that's basically fine
I think the presidents of the United
States ripping into Germany for its
hypocrisy in talking about the Russian
threat well bringing in 70 percent of
all of its natural gas through a
pipeline negotiated by its former prime
minister into into Germany I don't think
that that's wrong either however I think
that Vladimir Putin is sitting there and
he is wondering to himself whether
President Trump is really signaling that
if you were to make a move against
Estonia or Latvia or Lithuania that
President Trump would not actually bath
a NATO action against such a move
because the reality on the ground is
that the United States is in fact the
largest sponsor behind NATO we spend an
enormous amount of money on NATO every
year and that is for a reason America's
own benefit remember NATO was built in
the aftermath of World War Two in order
to curb German ambition and in order to
aim this alliance against Russia that
was in America's national interest it
created a more hegemonic a more
understandable and consistent social
order it prevented European wars that
have been plaguing the continent for
literally a thousand years it prevented
those European Wars from happening since
1945 there hasn't been an intra European
war except for depends on whether you
consider Yugoslavia European country or
not but if you do that was the only
European war there hasn't been an intern
ASEAN European war since nineteen since
1945 that is because of NATO that is
because of the United States's
commitment to this world order and yes
we were the chief sponsors of it but we
were also the chief beneficiaries of it
the United States is the largest most
powerful economy on earth and having a
more orderly World Order which we are
the of which we are the head is a good
thing for the United States well you
don't want is all of these
country's fragmenting and building up
new alliances you don't want Germany for
example breaking away from the EU
rearming and then siding with Russia
again we've had enough of that that
didn't work out great the first time so
the the the idea that we are going to
you know cast aspersions at NATO
generally I think is a huge mistake
that said the president's critique of
members of NATO for not doing enough and
the fact that they are free-riding he is
not wrong about any of that now Angela
Merkel is fighting back but she has
responded to President Trump noting that
she grew up under a Soviet controlled
regime in East Germany she has I myself
experienced that a part of Germany that
was controlled by the Soviet Union I am
very happy today we are united in
freedom as the Federal Republic of
Germany we decide our own policies and
make our own decisions Trump and earlier
said it said exactly the opposite he
said Germany is totally controlled by
Russia a lot of people in Germany very
upset about that well if you're that
upset about it perhaps the best thing
that you could do is to actually stop
importing enormous amounts of natural
gas from Russia I remember in the
aftermath of September 11th there was a
lot of talk about the United States
needing to get off of Saudi oil because
there was fear that we were generating
policy based on our dependence on OPEC
nations I didn't think that was
completely out of their own possibility
well the same thing is true here with
regard to Germany Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
Schumer are being cynical right now they
put out a joint statement on the Trump
Putin summit which is coming up and
here's what they say they say president
Trump's brazen insults and denigration
of one of America's most steadfast
allies Germany is an embarrassment his
behavior this morning is another
profoundly disturbing signal that the
president is more loyal to President
Putin than to our NATO allies that's a
weird critique considering that Trump is
ripping Germany for working too closely
with Putin right so even if you think
that Trump is working close to the Putin
or that he's friendly to Putin
you might want to wait until Trump
actually has his meeting with Putin his
face-to-face in which Trump will likely
be very very kind to Putin just as he
was very kind to kim jeong-hoon then I
think the critique is fair but if
Trump's critique of Germany is there too
close to Putin and your critique of
Trump is he's too close to Putin because
of what he just said about Germany I'm
not sure how you logically get from
point A to point B Pelosi and Schumer
say if the president leaves the Putin
meeting without ironclad assurances and
concrete steps sort of full cessation of
Russian attacks on our democracy the
meeting will not only be a failure it
will be a grave step backward for the
future of the international order and
global security allow me to say that
this is cynical hypocrisy by the
Democrats considering they were
perfectly fine with Barack Obama sitting
there in 2012 and openly telling dmitry
medvedev than the
into Russia that they that he wanted to
offer the Russian government flexibility
he needed flexibility from them and then
maybe he would be kinder to them during
his next election cycle during his
enduring his next presidential cycle you
know all of this is is deeply stupid
with that said do I want the President
of the United States to be harsher on
Russia you bet I do but I don't think
that this is good evidence that the
president is being weak on Russia it
seems to me the president is actually
pushing all of these European nations to
be harsher on Russia by spending more on
their own defense
maybe that's driven by Trump's weird
zero-sum game belief that the United
States is picking up the defense
spending for all of Europe
maybe it's driven by that regardless of
what it's driven by the outcome would be
a good outcome which would be a more
robust NATO not a less robust NATO if
they would spend more on their own
defense and then have the capacity to
defend themselves over time okay so
we're gonna do a couple of things I like
and then some things I hate and then we
will do a quick someone because it is
Wednesday so I've decided we're gonna go
through the Book of Psalms so let's do a
little bit of stuff that I like and then
we'll do some stuff I hate so the first
thing that I like today is the movie
Lincoln so I've never actually seen this
and watch when it came out in the
theater I was mostly concerned that Tony
Kushner who I think is one of the
world's most overrated writers that
creator of angels in America who wrote
the script from Lincoln was going to
turn this into sort of a in anti-bush
Ian routine considering this came out in
2012 I believe it's been it's been a
while since Lincoln came out but it was
available on Netflix for free and so I
finally started watching it the great
thing about the movies Daniel day-lewis
is performance so first of all it's a
star-studded cast Daniel day-lewis is
the best thing in at Sally Field is
terrific as Daniel daily as a Lincoln's
wife as as Mary Todd the I think Tommy
Lee Jones choose the scenery a fair bit
in this in this film but Daniel
day-lewis is spot-on because he is the
great actor of our generation without a
doubt we can only hope that he reverses
his decision to leave acting after
phantom thread my criticism of the movie
is that the movie is over it because
that is Tony Kushner write everything
Tony Kushner writes is a lot like Aaron
Sorkin where you just feel the writing
you feel the writing like the best
writers I don't think you actually feel
the writing you just feel the characters
I in this particular movie you feel a
lot of Tony Kushner there it's good Tony
Kushner meaning that it's the best of
what Tony Kushner has to offer but it's
like watching an Aaron Sorkin film when
you watch an Aaron Sorkin film it's like
when you watch a few good men it's like
hey look there's Jack
in playing Aaron Sorkin and oh my gosh
look at that there's Tom Cruise playing
Aaron Sorkin and look there's a female
playing Aaron Sorkin look at that that's
with all of his films the same thing is
sort of true when it comes to Tony
Kushner but here's here's some of the
preview for Lincoln if you haven't seen
it it's now available to watch free
streaming on Netflix we can't tell our
people they can vote YES on abolishing
slavery less at the same time we can
tell them that you're seeking a
negotiated peace it's either the
amendment or this Confederate peace you
cannot have bought how many hundreds of
thousands of dad Daniel administration
Congress must never declared equal those
who got created on equal
we're stepped out upon the world stage
now the faint of human dignity in our
hands blood spin spell to afford as this
moment now now now
Abraham Lincoln has asked us to work
with him to accomplish the death of
slavery no one's ever been loved so much
that people don't waste that power this
fight is for the United States okay so
what I like about it is that obvious is
very very Pro America film it's it's
very Spielberg in in the sense that
everything that Spielberg does sort of
has a gloss of like yellow sunshine over
it like everything that he does is
almost through a yellow filter that's
not meant literally it just means that
everything is done with the upshot
everything is very obvious into in
Steven Spielberg's direction like
interrex et the same way he directs
Lincoln basically and that means that
it's a real hagiography of Lincoln what
it does convey is is some of the
complexities that Lincoln had to face
and the political manipulation that
Lincoln was happy to be involved in or
was willing to be involved in in the
face of all of this it takes on some
serious racial issues it's it's
definitely worth watching it's
definitely worth watching I think it's a
very good movie I think it avoids me
being a great movie by about this much
but it but the performance is
particularly Daniel day-lewis are just
spectacular so go check that out okay
time for some things that I hate okay so
the first thing that I hate Sacha Baron
Cohen I find very funny I think the
Sacha Baron Cohen stuff is really funny
although I could use with a little less
of the bizarre nudity in some of his
films but Sasha Baron Cohen is doing a
new series apparently and he went after
Sarah Palin because we have to go over
people who are largely irrelevant in
American politics or at least have been
for what 10 years now I mean she she ran
for a vice president in 2008 in any case
Sarah Palin was apparently she was
essentially catfished by Sacha Baron
Cohen so Sarah Palin says that she and
water for daughters were duped into
apparently appearing on his new TV
series she says you got me Sacha feel
better now and what exactly happened she
said she was invited to appear on a
legit Showtime historical documentary
she was interviewed by what appeared to
be a disabled veteran in a wheelchair
she assumes that that was Sacha Baron
Cohen in disguise he peppered her with
questions she added adding that war that
were full of Hollywood isms disrespect
and sarcasm she said she finally had
enough and literally physically removed
her mic and walked out said the
disrespect of our US military
middle-class Americans via Cohen's
foreign commentaries under the guise of
interview questions was perverse she
said before she was purposefully taken
to the wrong airport after the interview
and missed her flight home so normally
when people get pranked I don't really
care like when people get pranked that's
sort of part of the game but if Sacha
Baron Cohen dressed up his disabled
veteran in order to prank Sarah Palin
that truly is disgusting like taking on
the aspect of somebody who'd been
disabled in an American foreign war to
prank somebody is really pretty file
there's nothing more sacred in America
than our veterans and that's
particularly true for veterans who have
taken damage in the line of duty and to
operate off a good-faith move by Sarah
Palin to talk with a wounded veteran
in order to prank her is just just gross
and I'm surprised if the left is willing
to stick with that but I guess maybe
they're willing to stick with anything
okay other things that I hate so there's
this video that's going around that's
really annoying and irritating and and
pretty bad of a young black kid who is
selling candy bars outside of a store
and a random old lady comes up and
demands to see a business license so
here is here is the the video
yeah you're really standing up for them
yelling at them okay who is this random
old lady and in her and her fervor to to
stop young people from selling things
next to next to a grocery store first of
all if the grocery store or the CVS
whatever this place is who wants to call
the cops and say listen this guy's
undercutting our price by selling like
directly outside and doesn't have a
business license that's fair but for the
random old lady to try to shut down
somebody's business I find really really
gross like in Los Angeles we have a lot
of people who sell fruit on street
corners right you see these people and
they have these cards and they're
selling fruit on street corners what's
the problem they're a bunch of people
who are really angry about this and I
understand if you don't want somebody
who's selling it like right in front of
your house because they're not in a
business district or something but the
idea that we have to have all these
licensing requirements for somebody to
run a food truck or for somebody to have
an ice-cream truck or for somebody to
sell candy on a street corner without
doing any sort of damage to the city I
just I find that really off-putting and
this is where the libertarian in me
comes out and I say that people should
really get off their high horse and
recognize and one of the things that
built this country was the fact that
young people were allowed to go out
there and make money for themselves by
engaging in commerce we want more people
engaging in commerce this kid right here
is trying to sell a product he is not
trying to mooch okay you could be out
there with a cup and he couldn't be out
there with a hat doing nothing instead
he's actually trying to sell a product
to people I don't see any problem with
that as a general rule and I find this
really often now of course the left only
cares about this because the lady is
white and the kids black it's the
implication that this is a racist thing
maybe it is a racist thing but I would
care about it whether it was it was
white or black you see this a lot
happening to white kids where you'll see
some little girl who's running a
lemonade stand and some idiot decides
they're gonna report hurts and local
government because she's operating a
lemonade stand without a license this is
basically that just the kid is black and
selling candy bars instead of lemonade
it's just as stupid it's just as gross
okay other things that I hate final
thing that I hate so Trevor Noah who
again is being treated as a political
commentator that the conflation between
comedians and political commentators is
highly irritating because it would be
fine if we could actually treat these
people as political commentators and
just say listen your political
commentary is stupid but instead what
happens is you say that political
commentary was really dumb and then the
comedian says when I'm Trevor Noah
and I don't really I
really care you know because have a
comedian need his him through the
Stephen Colbert
every time you say Colbert is saying
something dumb because well I'm a
comedian it's the clown nose on clown
nose off routine when they don't wanna
be criticized I'm a clown look at my
funny nose and then the minute that they
they want to say something serious off
comes the clown nose
I am a statesman John Stewart used to do
this better than anybody Trevor Noah's
doing it now he's got a serious face on
that's how you know he's not joking mode
and his serious face says that Trump is
just like African dictators Donald Trump
reminds me in many ways of many African
dictators you know his his his demeanor
his style who he presents himself as and
how he how he processes his power is
something that's all too familiar he's
just like an African dictator except for
the non forced Landry distributions the
non genocides that are happening in the
streets and the non ability to take over
the entire government make it a tool of
his will and then line his own pockets
dramatically see here's the thing you
know I don't care about Trump's aspect
everybody it's so fascinating to me
everybody seems to deeply deeply care
about President Trump as a human being
like Trump is a difference in kind he's
a different kind of person we have to
get inside his head we have to figure
out what he's thinking what is his
aspect what is his attitude what is he
trying to do I don't care about okay
like he's a person I don't know him I
don't care about him very much
that doesn't mean that I wouldn't help
him if I saw him like you know hit by a
car or something I'd help anybody hit by
a car but the problem is that everybody
is treating the President of the United
States personally as though he matters
he does not
he's an institutional cog this is why we
have a constitutional system I don't
believe that people are just sort of
born better in the United States and
burn worn worse in Africa for example I
don't think African dictators are
African dictators because people in
Africa are naturally worse because
that's stupid and there's no evidence to
back that I think that America has a
long cultural history of checks and
balances and so it doesn't matter what
Trump's attitude is it matters whether
the checks and balances actually operate
and they do I think if you took that
same African dictator the trevor know is
talking about and you plunked him down
in the Oval Office guess what you
wouldnt be able to do any of the stuff
he does in Africa because the system is
not built for it in Africa the system is
built for it here that's the genius of
the system it's one of the reasons why I
believe the Supreme Court matters and
why I believe the Constitution matters
it is the most durable document in human
history with
the creation of government I mean
democracies tend to collapse in on
themselves relatively quickly in the
American Republic has not only not
collapsed in on itself it's grown better
over time
at least not with regard to the
administrative state but everything else
in terms of the inclusion in terms of
its capacity in terms of the power of
the American economy all of these things
have grown over time because of the
durability of the Constitution not in
spite of them the same Trevor Noah
will sit there and whine about Trump
being like an African dictator will sit
there and wide about the shortcomings of
the US Constitution and why he wants one
branch the judiciary to have absolute
power over exactly how everything ought
to work in the country it's pretty
astonishing ok let's go through a quick
Psalm here because it is Wednesday so
we're on Psalm 2 we have begun our
journey through the Book of Psalms so in
Hebrew for those who care it's called
Tehillim ok which means Psalms and this
one is is one of the most frequently
cited in among sort of New Testament
scholars because it makes oblique
reference believe New Testament scholars
to Jesus as a Jew I don't believe that's
what the psalm is saying I'll explain
why so the psalm says why have nations
gathered and why do kingdoms think vain
things kings of a land stand up Nobles
take counsel together against the Lord
and His anointed let us break their
bands and cast off their cords from us
he who dwells in heaven laughs the Lord
mocks them then he speaks to them in his
wrath and he frightens them with his
sore displeasure but I have enthroned my
King on Zion my holy mount I will tell
of his decree the Lord said to me you
are my son this day I have begotten you
requested me and I will make nations
your inheritance in the ends of the
earth your possession you shall break
them with an iron rod like a Potter's
vessel you shall shatter them and now
you kings be wise be admonished you
judges of the earth serve the Lord with
fear and rejoice with quaking arm
yourselves with purity lest he become
angry and you perish in the way for in a
moment his wrath will be kindled the
praises of all who take refuge in him so
the section of this that people like to
cite in in the New Testament context is
of course the part where it talks about
you are my son this day I begotten you
and people who believe in the New
Testament Christians take that extremely
literally you know in Judaism Jews are
frequently referred to as God's children
the these the people of Israel are
frequently referred to in Psalms as
God's Son it's not unusual it's not it's
not an unusual language with regard to
Jews let's it's not the idea that it's
like literally God's son as Christians
interpreted so I just want to make that
clear but the interesting part of the
psalm is there's this very sort of
hegelian notion that if god doesn't
like somebody they're going to lose and
that if you disobey God then you're
going to lose then you look at the world
and you see a lot of evil people really
thrive well so how do you reconcile
those two things and I think the answer
lies in this particular verse from the
psalm it says request of me and I will
make nations your inheritance in the
ends of the earth your possession and
the word request is in Hebrew sha which
means ask of me what means really kind
of plead with me sort of and the idea
here is that God's justice is only going
to occur when those of us who believe in
God and believe in the judeo-christian
system actually repent of our sins and
lean on God for our moral system when
that happens there will be a natural
outgrowth of that and that will allow us
to gain a certain amount of power in in
the world order and I think that's been
true I think the reason judeo-christian
civilization has been so powerful is
specifically because we have clung to
particular values that inherently make
nations more powerful and wiser and
better I am NOT a multicultural list in
the sense that I don't believe that all
cultures are created equal
I believe that judeo-christian culture
judeo-christian civilizations the best
civilization ever put on earth at all at
any time the more pride we've taken it
and the more we request that God bring
us close within that context the better
we will do in the real world as well I
think this holds true for individuals
who try to hold by a certain level of a
biblical morality in their own lives
- ok we'll be back here tomorrow with
all of the latest updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018